we begin with some breaking news this is
not the sort of thing you expect to hear
you may find it shocking and certainly
upsetting I know I did but here's the
news people are mad at me on the
internet they are upset they're
scandalized they're calling me things
like fascist and bigot this is all of
course making me feel quite bad about
myself as someone who is so accustomed
to receiving unanimous Acclaim and
adulation and agreement all the time
everywhere I go so I don't know how to
deal with this
let's back up uh for a moment so you can
understand the context a few days ago a
leftist Twitter user and I inferred his
political leanings from the pride flag
in his bio
posted a video expressing his awe over
um the airport in Singapore
this is Singapore's airport as you can
see it's a rather impressive site it
looks like the uh futuristic Utopia in
every sci-fi movie right before the
robots start killing everyone and I mean
that in a good way
waterfall there is particularly
magnificent
um though In fairness I have seen
similar side set like LAX it's just that
those water flows waterfalls were
overflowing toilets our airports in
America are generally a different kind
of experience from what you just saw
there airports in the United States they
qualify as really nice if they have like
a food court with a Chipotle and more
than three electrical outlets in each
terminal so the bar is set a bit lower
admiring Singapore though has become
something of a trend online every so
often somebody usually somebody on the
left
will post a video uh like the one you
just saw or like this one extolling
Singapore the city for its clean green
eco-friendly approach watch
this place creates Gardens and parks in
the middle of its buildings that's
because in parts of Singapore you're
required to replace the land that you're
building on with this same amount of
greenery so the greenery that is lost on
the ground is replaced in the sky each
building must have Greenery that's
equivalent to at least 100 percent of
the land that it was built on but some
take it to the next level this building
has over 200 percent Greenery for the
land that it replaced this is Park Royal
and it's absolutely crazy how they
managed to include Greenery throughout
the building you can even go on a garden
walk here but all of this is not just
done for a more beautiful look there is
a functional reason as well seat
buildings with more Greenery end up
using less electricity produce less
waste and in general have a lower carbon
footprint you also improve the air
quality and keep the temperatures cooler
this rooftop is over 50 stories high and
it's pretty much entirely a garden and
the crazy part is that it's completely
open to the public this is a public area
now your mileage may vary a bit with the
Jumanji aesthetic where forests are
growing inside and on top of all the
buildings the real point is that the
city looks bright and clean and safe and
not at all like a post-apocalyptic
zombie-infested hellscape which sets it
apart from our cities which in so many
cases look like some sort of horrifying
mashup of The Walking Dead and the wire
like this for example what you see here
is Philadelphia
but it could be a random street in
nearly any major American city
there's a reason we don't have you know
very many carefully manicured public
parks located on the tops of our
buildings because if we did there'd be
almost immediately you know a drug
addict passed out on every bench and a
homeless guy taking a dump in every bush
people who look
with with envious lustful eyes at
Singapore's cleanliness and general lack
of fentanyl zombies and random street
thugs assaulting pedestrians have every
reason to be so Covetous when you
consider what our cities look like
but there's also a reason why Singapore
looks like Singapore in Philadelphia it
looks like Philadelphia
there are many reasons actually and not
all of them can or should be emulated
but in the tweet that got me into
trouble I mentioned one major factor
that to my mind we should adopt I
tweeted this
Singapore is able to have nice things in
part because they execute drug dealers
by hanging and they arrest even Petty
vandals and thieves and beat them with a
cane until they bleed we don't have nice
things because we aren't willing to do
what is required to maintain them
now that tweet has been viewed like 14
million times and 13.9 million of those
views apparently came from people who
were deeply offended by it on the right
and left
but offended as they may be the fact is
that Singapore isn't plagued by property
crime and violent crime nearly to the
extent that our country is in fact their
crime rates are among the lowest in the
world because
in part in large part they harshly
punish law Breakers
as mentioned in the Tweet thieves
robbers vandals similar malcontents are
subject to judicial caning drug
offenders can be given the same
treatment
and it's meted out to more serious
criminals like uh like rapists and
people convict of kidnapping often the
corporal punishment will be paired with
a prison sentence which depending on the
crime can be quite lengthy
we've heard a little bit actually about
this punishment in Singapore and the
methods that are used from westerners
who have made the mistake of committing
the crimes in Singapore that everyone
knows you aren't supposed to commit in
Singapore for instance a couple of years
ago the British media reported with
great alarm about the story of a British
national who got caught dealing drugs in
Singapore
which again
everybody even people don't live in
Singapore knows that Singapore is the
last place where you go to jail drugs
that's what he did and he received 20
years in prison to go along with a
caning that was so severe that he
couldn't sit down afterwards he had
trouble controlling his bowels because
of how badly he was beaten
he reported um that uh the the fear that
he felt and having to wait in line while
listening to the screams of other
inmates as they received their
punishments he's in one room waiting
this is the way he described it and they
bring people in one by one and they beat
them with the cane and you can hear them
screaming in agony and then they open
the door and it's your turn
not a pleasant experience
not one that I would ever want to
experience myself
but he got off easy compared to other
drug offenders because if in Singapore
you're caught with drugs over a certain
amount and it doesn't have to be all
that much 15 grams of heroin 30 grams of
cocaine for example you are
automatically charged with uh
trafficking drug trafficking it's
automatically assumed that you have that
because you want to traffic drugs
and in Singapore they simply do not
tolerate drug trafficking at all
so if you're convicted of drug
trafficking you are automatically
executed it is a mandatory sentence
and they will dull out this most severe
of punishments for you know a number of
crimes not just drug driving of course
murder terrorism kidnapping uh can also
warrant that and and other serious
crimes as well and the executions are
carried out usually swiftly death row
inmates are given four days notice not
four decades four days notice before
they're taken out usually at dawn and
they are dispatched by hanging
now it's often said that studies prove
that death penalty and other harsh
punishments are not effective deterrence
that's what we hear all the time in this
country it doesn't Studies have proven
Studies have proven it doesn't deter
anything
well seems to be working pretty well in
Singapore
which which in Singapore they can make
it through entire days okay in fact
dozens of days in a year without any
reported crimes at all
as a CNBC report marveled over uh
marveled over a few years ago Singapore
is so safe that many stores don't have
locks they don't lock their doors at
night and sometimes they don't even have
doors or locks to begin with
if capital punishment lacks a deterrent
element in our country it's obviously
because we hardly ever use it it's not
capital punishment itself it doesn't
deter crime it is the way that we go
about it
that lessens its deterrence Factor
there have only been something like 1500
total executions in our entire country
since the mid-1970s
and that number is decreasing all the
time
it's a small handful of people entire
across the entire country are executed
in any given year
and on the extremely rare occasion that
anybody is executed it happens decades
after the crime they committed out of
sight out of mind for the public and
after hundreds of appeals what this
means is that criminals they aren't
deterred by it because they know they
almost certainly won't receive that
penalty they know it won't happen to
them no matter what they do
it's not that they aren't scared of the
death penalty itself obviously anybody
would be scared of that is that they
don't believe the court system will have
the gumption to actually impose it on
them and in nearly every case they're
right
now when the death penalty or other
harsh penalties are immediate
and all but certain
it does have unsurprisingly a way of
dissuading potential criminals as it
turns out people do respond to
incentives and disincentives this is one
of the basic realities of of human
psychology is that every single person
on the planet responds to incentives and
disincentives
and the prospect of dangling at the end
of a rope until you die is a rather
powerful disincentive
it's not gonna be 100 effective
okay there are people who will risk it
but most people won't
for the pettier criminals the idea of
being stripped naked and beaten so hard
with a cane that the guy doing the
beating has to take breaks to let his
arm rest throughout your ordeal is also
a rather powerful disincentive
now our system of dealing with thieves
and vandals and those of that ilk is
laughably ineffective because in these
cases too the criminals aren't convinced
that there will be any significant
penalty and if they do wind up with a
short stint in prison the experience is
likely to only increase their street
cred and give them an opportunity to
spend time with and be influenced by
criminals even worse than themselves
but an added element of extremely
painful corporal punishment
creates a profound disincentive so that
even those unbothered by prison
would be bothered by this
caning is also and it is meant to be
humiliating degrading emasculating
which means that the experience isn't
going to enhance anybody's street cred
okay you're not going to get out of
prison bragging about getting caned
put another way it's not the kind of
thing that you can imagine a rapper you
know boasting about in a song
and that's precisely why it's an
effective form of punishment in fact
maybe this is like the easiest way to
think about this when you think about
what sort of penalty should we have for
criminals
think about it if it's the kind of
penalty you can imagine a rapper
bragging about in a song
that you know is becomes a big hit and
is and is and is uh streamed 100 million
times on Spotify if it's that kind of
penalty then it's not a good penalty
let's imagine penalties that they would
be too embarrassed and too ashamed to
brag about
those are the good penalties those are
the effective ones
now am I actually suggesting that we
should adopt these singapore-like
Draconian forms of Justice here in the
United States am I seriously advocating
that
yes absolutely of course I am corporal
punishment for convicted criminals that
shouldn't even be controversial okay
that's actually obviously the correct
thing to do
both both obvious and effective
and just
those who cause damage to another
person's body or livelihood or property
should be made to experience the sort of
physical suffering that might help them
appreciate the seriousness of their
crimes
our current system is not impressing
anyone with the seriousness of their
crimes
that's what the punishment is supposed
to do
we have it in our heads that well all
forms of physical punishment are
automatically cruel and unusual I've
heard this over and over again as in
response to you know this argument well
it's cruel and unusual punishment
as if it's just self-evident you can't
you can't simply assert that it's cruel
and unusual to impose uh the death
penalty or corporal punishment you have
to explain why you could call a cruel
and unusual
and in what sense is it either of those
things
I mean these punishments certainly
aren't unusual
on the contrary they are probably the
most usual sort of punishment imaginable
from a historical perspective
and they aren't cruel because the person
that they are inflicted on has chosen to
act in a way that warrants it
it is not cruel to assign undesirable
consequences to undesirable Behavior
it is on the contrary the only way to
maintain a civilized society
criminals and law Breakers must be made
to suffer if they aren't suffering then
it is not really a punishment
that's what a punishment is supposed to
do it's supposed to make you suffer
and so if we have a system where the
where the criminals are not suffering
then they're not being punished and we
are trying a system where we just
actually don't punish people for
committing crimes
now as for the death penalty for drug
traffickers this again to me seems
obvious they sell poison for profit
taking advantage of the most helpless
and miserable Among Us turning people in
entire communities into zombified husks
slowly dying while these parasitic
scumbags reap the rewards they deserve
to die for what they're doing to people
to our cities to our country
they deserve to die for it
fentanyl traffickers okay the people
that are those those zombies that you
saw in the in the clip of Philadelphia
that are they're walking around hunched
over
the people trafficking those drugs into
our communities they deserve to die I I
can't understand the argument to the
country you actually tell me they don't
deserve to die for doing that to people
do we need to keep them around
in what ways would we be harmed as a
society if the people that are doing
that uh if we are deprived of their
presence how are we harmed how are we
missing out
no our nation will be a better more
hopeful safer and more livable place
without them
now I'm not arguing that our country
should emulate Singapore in every
respect there are certainly things about
the country I don't like and I'm not
claiming that beating criminals and
hanging drug traffickers would on its
own solve all of our problems I
acknowledge that Singapore has other
advantages they have a smaller much more
homogeneous population for one and that
helps it to build and maintain
communities that aren't littered with
used heroin needles and reeking
constantly of weed and human urine like
our cities
but even so there is a lesson we could
learn here the lesson is that
Civilization
comes at a cost
if we have decided that nobody should
have to pay that price
well then we will no longer have
civilization
we live free and comfortable and gentle
lives and so we imagine
that everything is and should be
comfortable and gentle all the way down
what we don't realize is that this
freedom and comfort and gentleness has
been maintained
by tough men who are willing to do hard
and sometimes ugly things
if we insist now that those things must
not be done anymore because they
interfere with our comfortable illusions
then pretty soon we will no longer have
the Comfort or the freedom
we are we are surrendering our society
to its worst and most predatory factions
because we're too squeamish to stand up
to them to impose our will over them and
to force them to live like civilized
human beings which is what you're
supposed to do with criminals you stand
up to them you impose your will on them
you force them to behave you don't give
them an option
it's not putting them in jail for let's
hope they reform let's hope they see the
air in their ways and that they choose
of their own free will to be better
people
now we don't sit around waiting for that
well you know our children are getting
murdered in the street we don't sit
around waiting for it
we say we're not giving you an option
and if your crimes are bad enough we're
not going to worry about uh about
reforming you because you're done
there's no second strike
in other words
uh
these days we wish to have a
civilization without Justice
because Justice is too harsh a thing for
us to stomach
we say no to Justice which means we say
no to civilization
which means that rather than forcing the
Lawless dregs of humanity to pay the
price
we all have to pay it instead
I'll do it for this portion of the shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]